all day their hope had been fading
families had gathered here at Jakarta
Airport to find out the fate of their
relatives this couple were expecting
their son his wife and her two children
the younger a baby just over a year old
when we heard the news we had little
hope but we hoped for a miracle from
Allah a miracle that they survived the
first body is from the crash site have
been recovered 189 people were on board
the search and rescue Chief predicted no
survivors behind me you can see the
debris they've already gathered from the
crash site there's room for a lot more
to come boats are going day and night
from here as part of this search and
rescue operation jt6 when I took off
under these clear skies now it lies
underneath these waters scoured by
divers why it plunged into the sea just
13 minutes after takeoff is for now a
mystery I do pass whenever I thought
when the noise like an explosion
happened I was on the beach but it was
dark it was cloudy I didn't think of
anything I thought it was thunder but it
was different from thunder it was loud
the boeing 737 was brand new its pilots
experienced shortly after departure they
asked to come back then contact was lost
but the debris tells its own story one
of a brutal high velocity impact seats
wrenched apart even phone smashed to
pieces the plane had suffered a
technical issue on its previous flight
that was thought to have been resolved
it will form part of this investigation
the task tonight was locating the
wreckage tomorrow's will be retrieving
it Tom Cheshire Sky News in Jakarta